If you are living in a black and white world,
where everything is either good or bad, with
no shades of gray, and you feel sad and empty
with an intense fear of being left alone — then
you might be experiencing what’s known as
BPD.
Borderline Personality Disorder is a mental
health condition characterized by a distorted
self-image, along with difficulties regulating
emotions and maintaining relationships.
It affects around 1-2% of all adults.
Like all mental health disorders, it is considered
to be on a spectrum, meaning that it can manifest
in all sorts of ways, ranging from regular
outbursts of anger to severe forms of self-harm.
The causes of BPD aren't fully understood,
also because it goes hand in hand with addiction,
other mental health issues and eating disorders.
Environmental factors, such as a childhood
of neglect and abuse seem to play a role,—
but so may genetics.
Since science has not yet been able to find
any biological evidence to diagnose mental
disorders, we have to turn to symptoms to
see if someone may have BPD.
To illustrate this, meet Alex.
Alex is a 20 year-old college boy who has
always been sensitive, but lately also feels
isolated and extremely emotional.
He experiences five symptoms that are often
associated with the condition.
Alex experiences rapid changes in self-identity.
In a single day he can go from feeling godlike
to feeling worthless.
And in a crisis, he changes from one personality
to another.
This is when he goes through
moments of dissociation,
where he feels detached from his body — with
no sense of self at all.
Alex has what’s known as a Distorted Self-Image.
He experiences intense and unstable emotions.
The smallest setbacks can send his mind spiraling
out of control and make him end friendships
in an instant.
Every emotion he feels, he feels intensely.
Joy becomes euphoria and sadness turns into
depression.
This emotional rollercoaster leaves him exhausted
— that is when he dissociates.
He struggles with Impulsiveness.
When talking to his friends, Alex often feels
misunderstood.
With close to no self-control, he starts shouting
or lashing out.
Later, he feels ashamed.
To cope, he eats, does drugs, or turns violent
— often against himself.
He has an intense Fear of Abandonment.
When his girlfriend cancels their date at
the last minute, he breaks up with her, and
a few minutes later bombards her with texts,
asking for forgiveness.
He is constantly worried she will leave him,
and demands impossibly high
standards of reassurance.
All of this leads to Unstable Relationships.
When Alex fears he will be abandoned, he hurts
his friends for no obvious reason.
By pushing others away he thinks he can avoid
being pushed away himself.
He later feels ashamed and promises to change.
After an intense period of paranoia, Alex
wants to drop out of college, which at this
point is pretty much the only stable thing
left in his life.
It’s then that his best friend asks him
to seek help.
When Alex speaks to a professional, he learns
about BPD and that the typical treatments
are forms of psychotherapy - like CBT - cognitive
behavioral therapy, DBT - dialectical-behavioral
therapy or MBT - mentalization based therapy.
The psychiatrist also explains that in some
cases patients take medication, such as mood
stabilizers.
This can be important as over 50% of adolescents
that attempt to take their lives are diagnosed
with borderline personality disorder.
Understanding his condition is a relief — at
least he knows he’s not alone.
What do you think?
What can we do to help people with BPD?
Please share your thoughts or your own experiences
with this condition in the comments below.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com